because i told you that there were two
different booths we could get to
artificial general intelligence and one
scares the species out of me
which is this one where we build
something we just say bigger neural
networks ever more hardware and just
train like
more data and poof now it's very
powerful
that i think is the the most unsafe and
reckless approach
the alternative to that is the
intelligent
intelligible intelligence approach
instead where
we say neural networks is just a tool
to disk like for the first step to get
the intuition
but then we're going to spend also
serious resources
sources on other ai techniques for
demystifying this black box and figuring
out what's it actually doing
so we can convert it into something
that's equally intelligent but that we
actually understand
what it's doing maybe we can even prove
theorems about it that this car
here will never be hacked when it's
driving because here's the proof
uh there is a whole science of this
but it doesn't work for neural networks
there are big black boxes but it works
well and where
certain other kinds of codes right
that approach i think is much more
promising that's exactly why i'm working
on it
frankly not just because i think it's
cool for science but because i think
the more we understand i mean these
systems the better
the chance is that we can make them do
the things that are good for us that are
actually intended
not unintended so do you think it's
possible to prove
things about something as complicated as
a neural network
that's the hope well ideally there's no
reason it has to be
a neural network in the end either right
like we discovered
newton's laws of gravity with neural
network in newton's head
yes but that's not the way it's
programmed into the
navigation system of elon musk's rocket
anymore right it's written in
c plus plus or i don't know what
language he uses exactly
yeah and then there are software tools
called symbolic verification
the darpa and the us military has done a
lot of really great research on this
because they really want to understand
that when they build weapon systems they
don't just
go fire at random or malfunction right
and um
there's even a whole operating system
called cell 3 that's been developed by a
darpa grant where
you can actually mathematically prove
that this thing can never be hacked
well one day i hope that will be
something you can say about the os
that's running on our laptops too
as you know we're not there but i think
we should be ambitious
frankly and and
if we can use machine learning to help
do the proofs and so on as well right
then
it's much easier to verify that a proof
is correct
than to come up with a proof in the
first place that's really the core idea
here
if someone comes on your on your podcast
and says they proved the riemann
hypothesis
or some new sensational new theorem
it's not me oh it's much easier for some
one else to take some smart grad math
grad students to check oh there's an
error here on equation equation five
or this really checks out than it was to
discover the proof
yeah although some of those proofs are
pretty complicated but yes it's still
nevertheless much easier
to uh to verify the proof i love the
optimism
you know we kind of even with the
security of systems
there's a kind of cynicism that pervades
people who think about this which is
like oh it's hopeless
i mean in the same sense exactly like
you're saying when y'all now works i
would
must understand what's happening uh with
security people are just like well
it's always going there's always going
to be
um attack vectors yeah like uh
waste ways to attack the system but
you're right we're just very new with
these computational systems
we're new with these intelligent systems
and
it's not out of the realm of possibility
just like people
didn't understand the movement of the
stars and the planets and so on yeah
it's it's entirely possible that like
within
hopefully soon but it could be within a
hundred years we start to have
an obvious like laws of gravity about
intelligence
and uh god forbid about consciousness
too
that that one is agreed you know i think
um
of course if you're selling computers
that get hacked a lot that's in your
interest as a company that people think
it's impossible to make it safe so
nobody's going to get the idea of suing
you but
i want to really inject optimism here it
the there is
it's it's absolutely possible to do
much better than we're doing now and you
know
your laptop does so much stuff you don't
need
the music player to be super safe in
your in your future
self-driving car right if someone hacks
it and starts playing music you don't
like
the world on end but what you can do is
you can break out and say the drive
computer
that controls your safety must be
completely physically
decoupled entirely from the
entertainment system and it must
physically be such that it can't take on
over-the-air updates while you're
driving and it can be
it can have it's not that it can have
ultimately a some operating system on it
which is symbolically verified and
proven
uh that it's always gonna do what it's
gonna what it's supposed to do right
and we can basically have and companies
should take that into two they should
look at everything they do
and say what are the few systems in our
in our company
they threaten the whole life of the
company if they get hacked you know and
have
the highest standards for them and then
they can save money by
going for the el cheapo poorly
understood stuff for the rest you know
this this is very feasible i think
you